alors on va partir attention attention
au
départ 4 3
2 casque sur les oreilles lecteur de
musique en main 420 collégiens ont
déambulé ensemble à hencour au rythme
des consignes d'un enregistrement sonore
dirigez-vous vers la place du marché
allez vas-y déplace-toi l'occasion pour
eux de se rencontrer se découvrir
[Musique]
commencez à vous déplacer tranquillement
toujours de manière à avoir plusieurs
personnes dans votre champ de vision
gardez dans votre champ de vision
plusieurs personnes qui semblent
participer à la
pimanif mais aussi d'explorer le
quartier des SEP mars
d'élencour jetez un coup d'œil à la
sculpture sur la place la main divine de
Klaus
Schulz nous sommes en train d'écouter un
enregistrement qui nous parle de de
cette statue donc c'est la main divine
donc unarchitecte nous a expliqué par le
biais de nos petites oreillettes que que
c'était une main divine et queil devait
rien avoir et elle touche l' qui est par
terre pendant 30 minutes les élèves
deviennent finalement les interprètes de
la partition écrite par l'auteur de
cette création sonore moi j'essaie de
créer des partitions où je fais feu de
tout bois c'estd tout élément que je
trouve dans la ville
en fonction du thème qu'on commande
permet de de se mettre en danse voilà et
puis en plus j'aime bien essayer de
trouver à chaque fois un décalage de de
regarder la ville de avec un autre
regard voilà donc très souvent je prends
une uvre d'art j'en parle et hop
j'arrive à à quelque chose d'un peu
saugrenu incongru voilà qui qui
interpelle c'est pas sa jamais trop si
c'est sérieux si c'est du lar ou du
cochon des inserts de films de la
musique mais aussi des interview
d'architecte pour les organisateurs
l'essentiel reste avant tout le partage
de ces inst
d'exploration c'est une joyeuse
manifestation comme la traduction le
dirait alors cette occasion là est de se
rencontrer vraiment de faire des choses
ensemble ce qui est quand même le projet
artistique du prisme faire
ensemble c un plaisir de travailler avec
toi si tu allais prendre ta
douche merci pour votre
participation voici venue la fin de
notre happy manif spécial croisé des
[Applaudissements]
arts